[Music]
i want to take a step back just for for
people who are listening and say that
there are many reasons that i wanted to
have this conversation with you and
it is not specifically related to
gambling in the sense that what most
there are many things that interest me
about your life and your thinking and
my hope is that for people listening
they get a window into at least two
things
one would be
your methods of thinking frames and
works for thinking how you think about
thinking
and then also
your
personal approach to
health and fitness
because as people may have picked up
with some of the references
could you tell everyone listening
what your age is as we speak today
i'm 89
and for those people who can't see video
you look like you're in your 60s and i
am just
beyond excited to to hop right into that
so we're going to jump around quite a
bit we want to do this exactly
chronologically but
could you
perhaps describe
your approach to
health and fitness and you could you
could tackle that starting wherever you
like is it just that you were
given the right parents and out of the
box have tremendous genetics is there
more to it how would you begin to unpack
this
i kind of wandered into health and
fitness by
accident initially just like i wandered
into blackjack and roulette
i'm curious and always looking for
things to understand and uh i like the
idea of self-improvement too so
i i was walking uh behind the student
co-op one night when i was about 20 and
heard a bunch of clanking
i looked down in the basement and there
were some
fairly burly guys down there
pumping iron and i walked in and i said
you know this is this is a waste of time
this is ridiculous so one of them said
to me i'll bet you a milkshake that if
you work out with us for a year just
one hour
an evening three evenings a week you'll
double your strength in
a set of exercises that they uh
describe so i said i don't believe it
let's try it
so i went down and the four exercises
were
the squat
with
a barbell on a rack
the military overhead press
the bench press
and uh deadlift
own deadlift no i wasn't dead left it
was something else
i forgot the fourth one at the moment
but i'll think of it clean and jerk
maybe who knows or bent row
yeah
it was something along those lines but a
compound exercise like like the others
yeah so there was a fourth exercise so
anyhow
what happened was
i
i was a uh
i wouldn't say 98 pound weekly but maybe
uh 150 pound weekly
and at the end of the year i could
military press 185
which was
at least double what i started with i
could bench press 375
i could do
15 at uh 325
and i could
squat with 375
i could do sets
and uh forgot what the other one was
i wish i could remember it in any case i
was astounded that all this uh came to
pass
so it made me pay attention to uh
strength at least
and some time went by and i was a little
swimming because i got interested in
scuba diving
and then uh
one day in my
30s i was jogging along the beach with
my uh
brother-in-law
and he said let's go for a little jog i
went for about a quarter mile and i was
gasping i was 35 and then i remember i i
said this is awful i'm in terrible shape
i have to do something about this
so they had a book on aerobics by
somebody named ken cooper who has a had
a lab down in texas and started
in large part the aerobics revolution
that swept the country
so i started keeping track of his points
he gave you points for
various degrees of aerobic effort i
think if you
did a mile in
between 12 and 15 minutes you got one
point and you did between
10 and a half and 12 you got two points
and so forth
so i started trying to run a mile a day
and i did that well i ran a mile every
saturday to start with
and then
one saturday i just had to try a little
further so i ran two
and then three
and then i said i'll try a ten mile race
so i got another 10 mile race which was
kind of foolish
but
i finished and i did i did reasonably
well so then i said i'll try a marathon
so then i got into marathon running
and i really like that i did that for
about 20 years until i uh hurt my back
weightlifting
all my bad events have been from uh
pushing myself athletically
so hurting my back was probably the
worst single thing the herniated disc so
i had to stop had to stop heavy pounding
heavy running
but
20 years of road running
and
well more than that maybe 25 years and
marathoning
gave me i think a very good base for
going forward and so now i
do things like i walk about
three miles
three four times a week and i spend
about two days in the gym
doing stretching and
strength
core strengthening and so on a lot of
emphasis on core because of my back
which is just fine now
i was just going to ask how your
approach seems like it has evolved and
and
changed over time say after 50 years of
age or
yeah in the i mean in the last
say 40 years or so are there any
particular changes that you made in
addition to the core
strengthening to support the back that
you think have
contributed to your longevity
i've evolved i try to listen to my body
so
i do what i enjoy
and
the rule i started to follow was some is
better than none
and more up to a point is better than
less
so there's there's no excuse i mean
if you tell yourself gee i'm not going
to do this because i can't do the whole
program that's a big mistake just start
doing it and i find that if you start
doing it and you get used to it you find
more and more things that you kind of
like that you could build on and then
you just keep getting better at it
i was probably in my best shape at
around
55 to 65 because of all this
that is
that is inspiring i am just about to
turn 45 and
even amongst my just to say age cohort
it's very
common for me to see people giving up
even in their 40s and blaming it on age
but with you sitting in front of me
describing your trajectory and sort of
adaptive habits
i feel like those
those excuses don't hold a whole lot of
weight
is there any other advice
one thing that's pretty neat is uh
race walking i did that for a while and
that's something that is lower impact
than running
but you can get the same kind of aerobic
workout
so that's something i'd direct people
towards
what does your strength training look
like
now uh or over the last few decades
as i get older it declines i get weaker
and it gets a little harder to do things
and i i feel a little tired i can't do
as many uh reps or sets of things
so
i have a mix of things that i do now i
will
do
squats
and
usually now just body weight
and i try to i'll do dumbbell squats
or
lunges with a lot of emphasis on one leg
and then she has to do a lot a lot of
weight on the other leg
do pull ups
and
i think the best i've done recently
which is not very much is four underhand
pull-ups and two overhand pull-ups
i used to be able to ten years ago i
could do a dozen of each
and
let's see what else
well i do
a lot of back exercises regularly
on the map and that's very helpful for
keeping my back in shape and keeping my
core
in pretty good condition
you